los 40 actividades
a cabo aquí en américa y en europa como
rechazo al proceso electoral que se
lleva a cabo y nicaragua en el que el
presidente daniel ortega busca
perpetuarse en el poder de eliminar la
competencia política con la cancelación
de partidos opositores y el
encarcelamiento de siete aspirantes
presidenciales sus organizadores le
llaman la gran marcha mundial e incluye
costa rica- destino de lubricar agua
entre los migrantes también de los
refugiados que salieron del país a
partir de la crisis de 2018
[Aplausos]
y denunciando la parte electoral la
represión de los asesinan donde los
campesinos y el nuestro hermano
no pueden hablar
las maras de abril exigimos justicia
seguir impunidad y nicaragua necesita de
libertad y democracia porque esta
elección es un azar
i
los nicaragüenses están votando
obligados yo tengo familia en el
gobierno y los obligaron a votar tenían
que presentar sino el lunes estaban
despedidos esa no es una elección les
diste más bajo ningún punto de vista
[Música]
la denuncia de estos nicaragüenses es
respaldada por organismos
internacionales de derechos humanos como
la comisión interamericana de la
organización de estados américanos y la
oficina del alto comisionado de la onu
para los derechos humanos que esta
semana dijeron que existe una falta de
libertades y garantías en nicaragua ante
la elección esto también ha sido
denunciado por gran parte de la
comunidad internacional
particularmente los países del
hemisferio y del continente europeo